lino zambito et ken pereira ont été des
acteurs principaux de la commission
charbonneau qui a fait partie du paysage
québécois pendant quatre ans ce soir on
vous emmène dans les coulisses de la
commission rencontrer des gens dont la
vie a été changé à cette expérience
chacun de vous a forcément dans la mise
à
réussi mon défi de ne pas passer
commande et sélective des tgv
dans ma tête ça en fait
le gouvernement annonce la mise en place
d'une commission denquête c'est la juge
france charbonneau qui va diriger cette
commission
regardez l'octroi des contrats dans le
milieu de la construction
pour les 15 dernières années ajoutez-y
une part de financement juste pour être
certain qu'on manque pas de travail on
revoir ce crime organisé ce matin une de
ces régles hausse était de payer une
cote au clan sicilien zec oui dans ma
tête je me disais combien de l'asseoir
cette commission la chance la commission
avec une bande d'analysé policiens
laurent pollution n'a rien dit aux
personnes que sous gta contact avec
personne je vois pas quel système est
fatalement pour défendre ceux qui
dénoncent est stationnée devant la
résidence et puis ça c'est lumière
ouverte le soir par exemple juste pour
un semis dès que tu es n'est pas requis
dans la société
un moment donné si c'est quelque chose
on pourrait obliger étude devra répondre
les gens réclamaient si on peut dire
l'audition de témoins comme marc bibeau
qui était le grand argentier du parti
libéral marc bibeau
pourquoi vous l'avez promis d'en boire
ne discuterait pas de toute façon
particulière ça c'est sûr et certain
le public se pose des questions sur des
réseaux d'influencé
tout cela est frappée d'un interdit de
publication